puddle ripples on both opening logos a
pretty heavy-handed sign that nothing
new awaits us in this film in the last
movie was 87 miles southwest of Isla
Nublar and I don't doubt its relation to
Costa Rica but damn at least be
consistent about how you describe where
these islands are in relation to things
that said movie still thinks we give a
shit about where any of this takes place
and this is such a lovely area it has
the best green screens in the entire
world
also in Spielberg on set today No sweet
let's go with the quick and easy green
screen shot hurry movie requires the
absolute most extreme father-son
adventure conceivable by man in order to
even have a plot also that's definitely
Tommy Tomasino from The Sixth Sense who
I've sworn to notice and hate for all
time on behalf of Haley Joel Osment
come on pretty much had it with this
mystery killing the last movie showed
how thrilling it can be when you can see
the danger coming the only dinosaurs
that could've done this are the
pterodactyls which the Jurassic Park
series has given the finger to so far
it's almost as though this movie's CGI
was specifically created to insult Stan
Winston actually Charlie does have
herbivores it really wouldn't be
interesting fighting with each other
dr. grant would be amazing at cinemasins
what a freakin buzzkill this asshole is
I am almost certain that they wanted
Alan and Ellie to be married and
together on the adventure in this movie
but they aren't because Alan's going to
need someone to call who can send the
entire military to save him later great
guy
no no he is you take that back all our
theories about rapture intelligence what
they were capable of we weren't even
close
tell me I think that was the next thing
he was going to do until you interrupted
with your new husband I mean until you
interrupted he was smarter than dolphins
or whales they were smarter than
primates but still tamable by the movie
after this one because reasons the
Raptor was capable of sophisticated
vocalizations which we heard in the last
scene they really wanted to rub that
Alan isn't with Ellie anymore thing into
our faces didn't they are you saying
that you wouldn't want to get on to Isla
Sorna and study them if you have the
chance no force on earth or heaven
could get me on that island oh yeah so
why am i watching Jurassic Park 3 then
also hilariously over-the-top statement
designed for comedic reversal set up
cliche you can feel the difference sexy
archeology gonna back up in four weeks
dr. grant once again has financial
troubles that will make him easy to buy
when it comes to going to Isla Sorna
this is brilliant Billy really it is sad
to say just a little bit late dr. grant
sketchy funding offer arrives during
discussion of projects dwindling funds
we have permission to fly low grant
somehow believes this pushy couple when
they say all they want to do is fly over
the island no force on earth or heaven
could get dr. grant on that island so a
private jet will have to do even with
what I pay could you afford a better bag
no way
this one's lucky Jurassic Park franchise
goes for back-to-back lucky packs in
back-to-back movies one of the many
ill-advised ideas this movie crapped out
Allan Jurassic Park 3 you can't tell you
enough how much it hates you
franchise totally takes the day off and
borrows the helicopter arrival music
from the first movie for the plane
around music in the third movie how are
the third movie in a row only the good
dinosaurs are visible at first
Amanda honey dr. grant said that's a bad
idea what he says it's a bad idea what
the bad idea
Tay Leone tries to be more annoying than
her bad boys character and this movie is
actively trying to get the audience to
mutiny right about now it's a Twitter
source I don't think so
it sounds bigger it sounds bigger dan
this guy didn't even graduate from the
Prometheus school of running away from
things everyone survives this plane
crash but only because we're on dinosaur
island all those white people to eat in
the dinosaur chooses the one black guy
that's totally racist all the remaining
white people survive this dinosaur
playing soccer I'm going to guess there
were easier ways for this dinosaur to
chase everybody but miraculous escape is
miraculous I guess nobody just because
they all run does not mean dr. grant
would then also run he believes standing
still is the best way to survive but
then abandons it to become the last guy
in line in the stupid runaway Party the
fuck run through the woods was just an
excuse to get these two Titanic
dinosaurs to start fighting which I'm
absolutely fine
however epic fight takes like 30 seconds
and is basically a waste of our time we
called everyone we did everything we
could
so Paul and Amanda thought it was a
better story to say there were a couple
of thrill-seekers looking for a guide
rather than telling dr. grant about
their missing son wouldn't have been
more likely to go with a true story
rather than the lie oh sorry
divorced couple is definitely going to
start loving each other again because of
the adventure cliche
in Jen's list because it was nothing
less than it makes it wonder what else
they're up to the t-virus
so mr. Kirby tell me when you climb k2
are we really gonna spend time
interrogating an already known liar
about his k2 exploits no such thing as
Kirby Enterprises that's on you guys
actually even didn't bother to check out
the business before you agreed to go on
this trip also how did mr. Kirby collect
enough cash with his paint and tile
store to rent a private jet with three
mercenary guys who would dare to fly in
restricted airspace okay fine go ahead
and scream and then when that tricyclic
plotz attacks you don't come crying to
me skip Wow isla Sorna continues to
provide a bounty of convenience as dr.
Grant's beeline path to the coast just
happens to pass right by crucial missing
kid evidence the silence should be
called isla coincidence battery's dead I
got an idea I'll power this camera with
my magnet batteries which are surely the
same this is not the same dialog from
the first scene gives us leave it on
what the hell is that all about the
skeleton of Ben manages to make an
appearance but how dinosaurs didn't
finish off the rest of his body makes me
realize the movie you just wanted to
have a skeleton in it Amanda - science
degree where there just happens to be a
brilliantly lit nest of eggs gleaming
like a treasure and an RPG you should
come look at this cliche I just stole
some Raptor eggs face Jesus these two
keep taking turns yelling and scolding
each other for it if they listen to dr.
grant and shut the fuck up and do what
he says the movie would probably be over
by now but to make the length of a
normal feature film these two have to be
some of the most clueless self-centered
morons ever put the film Raptors run
around like ghosts in horror movies but
you mean the vending machines are
powered off guy who knows better decides
to smash a vending machine because
clearly they haven't made enough noise
already also this is something that
definitely needed the element of
surprise so that everyone could be
startled and unsettled even more than
they already are
can't you just go to the one that's
already smashed no I guess you're going
hungry then okay so I'll give you that
the rampers are smart but definitely not
this smart you mean to tell me that this
asshole would rather pretend like he's
encased in formaldehyde rather than just
go in for the attack
superfast raptor is super slow at
chasing humans being chased by raptors
here's a handy heard of dinos for you to
lose yourselves in also when in doubt
just try to replicate from the first
movie on a bigger scale while being
blurrier and edited more rapidly
so we the Raptor didn't hear that in
city traffic they actually said it true
yeah but how did they know that you'd go
back to find his body
honestly they have the collective power
to just track these fools down on their
own but on trickery so why did they even
bother sensing that it's the villain in
the movie the Raptor takes his sweet-ass
time here instead of killing grant
immediately so that grant has time to
escape seriously so the kid is here
right now ready to throw smoke bombs and
save dr. grant because he just happens
to be in the area so this is missing kid
ex machina I guess seriously maybe the
stupidest thing any Jurassic Park movie
asks the viewer to swallow even worse
than motorcycle Raptor Bros is the fact
that this dumbass 12 year old survived
eight weeks on dinosaur island I mean a
goddamn week's last movie a heavenly
armed force was driven off the island in
two days this movie's adult started
dying off almost on touchdown but this
kid because he reads dinosaur books has
lasted eight weeks
my king ass also I guess Eric learned
how to cut his own hair after being on
this island for eight weeks I read both
of your books because every kid that
manages to run into dr. grant has read
his books also kid eats a Nestle crutch
which when you combine it with the
crackles in the last movie means this
series is extremely high on crisp rice
chocolate bars and I just use the last
of the gas grenades phew good thing
engine left a perfect eight week supply
behind when they cleared out this is a
t-rex pee how'd you get it you don't
wanna know because even the
screenwriters don't know I'm astonished
that you've lasted eight weeks in this
island yeah but the movie isn't ah now
they were up in a tree the no yelling on
dinosaur island room is free to be
abused even by dinosaur scientists and
this movie really makes me miss Stan
Winston Eric's always been a strong
little kid he probably would have found
his way to dinosaur island without your
permission I'm so sorry that you have to
be here
this is actress Tay Leone talking to
William H Macy which got filmed and made
the final cut the super smart Raptors
who know these assholes are here do not
come back in the morning for vengeance
or breakfast
let's my dad's satellite phone later we
find out this is inside the giant
dinosaur so how the fuck can he hear
from here also despite the fact that the
satellite phone is shown here in a
second to not be with the parents
somehow this island is small enough that
Eric's yelling can be heard by the
parents and the parents somehow couldn't
hear the phone what's going on there's
nothing but jungle around them but they
amazingly find each other in a giant
clearing made explicitly for reunions my
phone
yeah you're suddenly where is it I don't
have it well then that makes this the
luckiest sunlight phone call ever
somehow the kid managed to hear it you
guys all happen to be in virtually the
same area when it began to ring and a
dinosaur managed to eat it whole when
I'm breaking it making this reunion
possible spinosaurus managed to make it
through the jungle without being heard
until the satellite phone began ringing
oh my god if that isn't the luckiest
damn hole in the fence I've ever seen in
my freakin life premature relaxation
movie that just showed us that huge ass
dino crushing a metal fence like paper
expects us to believe this door can hold
it oh and you want to give me the bag
back okay Billy I got it first off Billy
is way too suspicious about this bag for
someone who wants to keep its contents
secret second off grant assigns for no
reason to bear the burden of the bag
just so we can have this scene about
what's in the stupid bag it's not a
Jurassic Park movie if someone isn't
trying to smuggle something Dino related
off the island nope seriously every
movie I bet your asset world has some
theme park and buster trying to smuggle
a baby Dino inside a suitcase or some
you watch steal Raptors oh it all makes
sense
what like the rappers weren't going to
attack you without the Raptor eggs since
when do Raptors need a reason to go
after you but I did it with the best
intentions with the best intentions some
of the worst things imaginable up being
done with the best intentions you're
right no more good intentions for me I'm
swearing act off only evil intentions
from here on it you're no better than
the people that built this case Danko I
hate Billy but Jesus that's way over the
top and harshness grant grant still
thinks taking the only path left is a
good idea after the first path he chose
nearly killed it no one gives a
pterodactyl's the Jason Voorhees of
dinosaurs also how in the fuck could
this thing fly around and land without
anyone hearing it also you'd think we'd
have seen one of these crew fly around
the island during the movie but nope
they're all laying low for maximum
surprise value
I've been carrying the parachute around
with me the whole time you know just in
case we got into this exact situation
good thing I told that story about
hang-gliding earlier or else this would
seem totally made up
man it's amazing how the entire rest of
this bridge that had that one part
collapse right away has stayed intact
for this race against Eric's death guy
who was just revealed as a selfish
asshole gets immediate chance to redeem
himself because this screenwriter runs a
tight ship a boring ship but tighten the
monetary dactyl apparently pieced out
after throwing Eric to her young and
allows this escape all dinosaurs must
slowly stock their human prey for fear
of ending the movie too early hope you
can swim well I wish I could say that
was unexpected but at this point
spectator docked oh thank god mr. Kirby
learned to swim in the last year am i
right also thank God for the audience's
sake that that little anecdote from
earlier paid off in some tiny
insignificant way dactyl barely pushes
door open for dramatic effect which
makes us think danger but it's really
just so we can see them fly prettily to
freedom later which makes no sense
because of the thing we talk about in
the next sin okay so the pterodactyls
have been living in Thunderdome this
whole time but in the last movie they
were flying around free and they're the
only assholes who could have killed the
boat guys in the beginning so where they
locked in this thing the whole time or
are they free to come and go I really
hope these kidnappers get a happy ending
they're just the best aren't they I have
a theory that there are two kinds of
boys those that want to be astronomers
and those that want to be astronauts for
girls well they're lucky we even show
them a telescope watch let's make a
profession out of it
this river takes them by a field of
completely harmless and beautiful
dinosaurs instead of a field of raptors
and t-rexes because even the fucking
river bowels to the screenwriters whim
or something dr. grant Billy was right
about fucking one well I made fun of the
island for seeming too small earlier but
damn how many hours down a river do
these assholes have to travel to reach
the fucking coast
dark malice or only irony that hateful
King irony okay so it's almost 7:00 a.m.
here and what we think is the Washington
DC area after looking at a license plate
earlier in the movie we just saw these
guys boating down the river when it was
daytime this island is 207 miles west of
Costa Rica a country that operates in
the central time zone and 207 miles west
ain't to the central time zone so is
this movie saying they've been boating
for so long it's nearly 6 a.m. where
they are and totally dark outside only
an hour behind le so what the fuck
wait a second this cage was completely
submerged in the water remember they
were so underneath the water that the
spinosaur couldn't find them so how did
they hit the bottom of the river but
still be able to go for air in the
middle of the terrible rainstorm the
Spinosaurus hears and falls for this
distraction despite having a perfectly
good victim in front of it
Finding Nemo lighting underwater allows
dr. grant to find what he needs now I
just need to figure out what light
source could possibly penetrate the
water this far below during a rainstorm
and more importantly where or what that
light source even is you want me to
lasso the moon Mary this flare gun still
works and the water apparently has some
sort of Exxon spill on the surface or
maybe it's just a comment on how
dinosaurs became oral I'm not quite sure
what to make of this actually angry
dinosaur runs away completely instead of
just around this patch of fire here and
back at his intended target remember
when we went fishing a couple of summers
ago nope skip I definitely reel of my
ex-husband face do you think so she
thinks you stole the eggs it's because
she's a woman isn't it if this asshole
blows through one of these things and is
actually able to talk to her confuse the
Raptors I just might scream movie wants
you to think the Raptor blow box and
something to do with the escape when it
was really just the chopper noises Ellie
has the power to get the Navy and the
Marines to come on a rescue mission
she said the Navy in well one sort of
needs the other to get where they're
going but I hear what you say that girl
if also how did they find Billy before
they found everyone else did they just
get here
pterodactyls have been nothing but
raging murder Birds this whole movie but
to facilitate a happy ending they're
done with that now just looking for a
new home as all pterodactyls waited a
long goddamn time but try flying off the
island I mean how long since the last
movie also somehow the fourth movie will
completely gloss over these escaped
pterodactyls I guarantee it seriously
these guys well at least it was short
but hey those pterodactyls are totally
gonna kill everyone in San Diego now
aren't they you mean Election sideways
citizen Ruth the bow Schmitt and
Nebraska Alexander Payne you mean most
of those I just mentioned Jim Taylor -
what the hell this is like when you find
out JJ Abrams wrote Armageddon and
you're like yeah but who really wrote
this
Allen
you're still the best yes so recapping
the Knights of the Golden Circle was a
southern extremist group operating in
the north
to subvert Union forces Amanda hey I'm
looking for a man to hug and kiss I came
home like I always do and I went in the
front door and I took off my coat and I
put down my briefcase and I said honey
I'm home only there was no one there
there's a boat rescue boat no no sir
something left behind but it floats they
love
daddy
Oh Billy I can show you the world
shining shimmering